Wednesday Season 2 is shaping up to be huge,
with a big mystery about who's behind those
threatening messages, the possible return
of Miss Thornhill and Principal Weems, and
perhaps a secret new master controlling the
Hyde.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'll be explaining everything you
can look forward to in the second season of
Wednesday.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
Laurel, aka Miss Thornhill, the evil mastermind
behind everything in Season 1, ends up in
a really bad way by the final episode, covered
in bees and with Wednesday's boot coming down
to stomp her in the face.
Many people have assumed this means the villainous
school teacher is dead, but I don't think
that's the case and I'm pretty certain Netflix
will want to bring Christina Ricci back to
the show.
There's also the fact we never see what happens
to her body after Wednesday's stomp, and a
great comment by movie lover "Mojolytical"
points out that Crackstone's ring will probably
have something to do with Laurel's return.
As the evil resurrected pilgrim burned up,
the ring on his finger fell to the ground,
and there was a deliberate slow-motion close-up
shot of the ring, a signal that it will surely
play a part in the future.
At the end, she was also lying on the ground
not far from where Crackstone's ring fell,
so if we assume she survived and crawled off,
she could have easily spotted the ring, taking
it with her.
The ring features a kraken – a legendary
sea monster – wrapping its tentacles around
a ship.
This feels like a hint that the villainous
Laurel and Tyler are part of an even bigger
monstrous plot directed at Wednesday and perhaps
the entire Addams family.
Were Laurel Gates and Tyler just pawns in
a bigger game?
A character who appeared to be a lot more
dead by the end of Season 1 was Principal
Weems, who was injected with deadly Nightshade
poison by Laurel after she and Wednesday confronted
her.
Now, tons of you have said you really aren't
ready for Larissa Weems to be gone, and I
do think there's a decent possibility that
Weems secretly survived.
Given Weems and Wednesday knew about Laurel's
predilection for chemical manipulation, Weems
might have consumed an antidote earlier to
counteract the poison.
Weems is also a shapeshifter, so it's possible
she cast an illusion to show herself dying,
but in reality she was OK.
Now, I'm not saying that Weems is alive for
sure, as it can cheapen a character's sacrifice
if a death is too easily reversed in a movie
or TV show.
However, we never saw a funeral for Weems
like we did with the dead mayor, and Gwendoline
Christie said the following in an interview
about Season 2:
"We haven't seen her put in the ground, have
we?
I feel like Larissa Weems would not really
be prepared to entertain or be dominated by
anything as commonplace as death."
The last few moments of the finale leave us
with a big question about who could be behind
the threatening messages on Wednesday's new
phone.
Although I expect Laurel to be returning,
I doubt it's her, but it is likely to be the
main villain for Season 2, so let's run through
the likeliest candidates.
A great comment by movie lover "Fabula Sumus"
says it will turn out to be Xavier's father,
a character we haven't yet met, but who was
mentioned multiple times in Season 1.
My dad's a psychic.
Vincent Thorpe.
My brother's his number one fan.
Watched his Vegas Special so many times, I'm
surprised it's not imprinted on his eyeballs.
Xavier's dad appears to be quite a cold character
and uninterested in his son.
He didn't show up on Parents' Weekend or when
he was arrested, and he's uncaring about some
of the difficulties Xavier experiences with
his powers.
My father thinks that my mental health is
a PR problem that he needs to manage.
Vincent could have some dark secrets from
his former time at Nevermore that he'd prefer
were kept quiet.
So if he discovered Wednesday has been snooping
around, he might have decided to scare her
off further investigations.
As Xavier's dad, it wouldn't be too difficult
for him to access his son's phone to get Wednesday's
number and send her the threatening texts.
Thanks to his fame, he might be recruited
as the new principal to replace Weems.
And given that Xavier's family already met
the Addams family in the past...
It was my godmother's funeral.
Apparently she was friends with your grandmother.
...it'd be interesting to see how he interacts
with Morticia and Gomez if they cross paths
again.
A suspicious character we haven't met yet
is Gideon, the MorningSong cult leader mentioned
by Gabrielle, Bianca's mum.
Gideon said you'd resist.
You think he'd give a damn about some single
mom and her daughter if we weren't sirens?
I think the cult may have designs on Jericho
and its inhabitants.
For example, we saw how Bianca's mother convinced
Lucas to download the cult's self-help app
just in the weekend she came to visit.
Although Bianca later persuaded him to ditch
it, I think MorningSong may try to recruit
more normies from the town and perhaps even
Nevermore students who, with their powers
and abilities, could be a way of boosting
the cult and its influence.
They may already have some nefarious, secret
activities they're engaged in at the Academy
or in the town and might be trying to scare
off Wednesday from snooping around any further
with the threatening messages.
A possible character we have met who could
be the stalker is Yoko the vampire, as many
of you've pointed out.
Indeed, Yoko was namedropped quite a few times,
but didn't get many lines, so I think she
and perhaps the vampires as a whole might
get more focus in the second season.
But why would Yoko hold a grudge against Wednesday?
Well, a smallish reason might be how Enid
went to room-share with Yoko after she fell
out with Wednesday, and they really seemed
to hit it off.
Yoko and I are so in sync that she's begging
me to be her new roomie.
But later Enid dumped Yoko to room again with
Wednesday.
A more significant reason though might be
that Yoko has some history with Wednesday's
mother Morticia, as apparently many of the
vampires at Nevermore have been there for
a very long time.
Those are the Fangs, AKA vampires.
Some of them have literally been here for
decades.
The sheriff is another existing character
with reasons to dislike Wednesday.
He was already suspicious of her in the first
episode because of his history with her family.
I'm gonna keep my eye on you.
He might also resent her for exposing his
son Tyler as a Hyde;
and given his job, he could probably find
out her number to send her the messages.
Another possibility is Kent, the Siren guy
who was thumped in the face by Thing and about
whom Wednesday didn't hide what she thought
in front of the other Nightshades when she
explained how she'd discovered their secret
meeting room.
I thought we just snapped twice.
Well, aren't you the brightest in the bunch?
There's also Lucas.
Although he turned good by the end thanks
to Bianca, he and his mates have an antagonistic
history with Wednesday and she fought them
after they harassed her at the coffee shop.
It's a long shot, but another possibility
is that Wednesday's stalker is the jock from
her former high school who bullied her brother
Pugsley.
He might have tracked her down in Jericho
and is looking for revenge for the piranhas
in the swimming pool.
The showrunners have already confirmed that
although the series is focused around Wednesday,
they do plan to bring back the rest of the
Addams Family in Season 2.
Some fun ideas are that Pugsley could attend
Nevermore and Morticia could even take over
as principal for the missing Weems.
Given the former principal's animosity to
Morticia, this could be really interesting
especially if Weems turns out to be still
alive.
Uncle Fester will surely be back too, and
there were many teases for another Cousin
Itt making an appearance next season, via
the portraits of Ignatius Itt in the basement
of the Nightshade Society.
But just before Wednesday returns to Nevermore,
could we also get some time where she goes
to see Enid in San Francisco?
I can pretty much guarantee fog and drizzle
every day.
Sounds tempting.
The very final shot of the season sees a chained-up
Tyler being taken away, but then Hyding out
into his monster form.
An interesting detail that another of our
movie lovers points out here is that Tyler
hyding out happens just as Wednesday's car
is passing the truck transporting his, which
could suggest Wednesday is his new master.
If it were the case the best explanation I
can think of is that Wednesday locking him
up and torturing him, inflicted a trauma that
somehow bonded him to her.
Born of mutation, the Hyde lays dormant until
unleashed by a traumatic event.
I think for Tyler's Season 2 arc he may seek
out his mother, who was never explicitly confirmed
to be dead.
She was however locked up as a Hyde and perhaps
he'll find her if he's being taken to the
same facility, and I think there could be
a possible redemption storyline for him there.
And if you want to discover all the amazing
details and easter eggs you might have missed
in Wednesday, like the many inspirations for
Jenna Ortega's Rave'N dance, tap here to watch
my video on that.
There's also a link in the video description.
So, what are your predictions or what would
you like to see happen in a second season
of Wednesday?
Let me know in the comments below.
And if you enjoyed this video do leave a thumbs-up,
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for enjoying Wednesday with me and
hope you have a marvellous movie-loving week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!